hey guys welcome to the Evan and Kaelin
podcast the podcast that's forever
changing get also trying to stay at the
same does that make sense I feel like
it's kind of close to like several other
interests
I'm so unoriginal now it's hard to come
up with like new new things to say at
the beginning of every episode 36
episodes in I gave up a long time ago I
was like you're like no and you've kind
of carried the torch it's interesting
because it's easier when you have a
formula and yet it's also harder when
you have a formula it's like the same
issue that we're trying to figure out
our thoughts on for the main channel
yeah well yours that might be a
different topic for another day but in
today's episode we have huge news like I
think so the biggest YouTube news since
the ad pocalypse since we started yes
because we started our channel right
after ad pocalypse and I swear we're not
trying to become a YouTube news channel
but there's just too much news but I
mean if you guys are watching this
podcast you guys like YouTube and if you
guys like YouTube I feel like you should
know about it and I don't know I feel
like it's we're gonna have interesting
conversations about it and we might as
well have those interesting
conversations on a podcast as opposed to
just like on a walk on a walk yeah so
I've been really excited to talk to you
out this but anyways we're not only
gonna be talking about the huge new
YouTube news we're also gonna be talking
about how I almost slice my foot open
how we revisited our very first project
we ever did on the main channel looking
at twitch and YouTube and comparing the
revenue sources between those since
we've been on twitch for a little bit
now we have more thoughts and if we have
time with and we might do a Q&A it
depends on how long we talk about the
big new new YouTube news all right
jumping right into it want to talk about
your toe no I'm ready to talk about it I
mean it's it's it's interesting because
I feel like for the longest time I
haven't been too scared
of glass I haven't had any like bad
experiences with glass and I just had my
first bad experience with it and how
like unexpectedly dangerous that can be
because I feel like my mom was always
worried about me around glass and
anytime up to this point up until like
two days ago it hasn't been that big of
a deal when glass is broken or anything
like that
oh my god it's fine but anyways getting
to what happened we are trying to like
figure out what lighting we're using in
this desk so right now we just have like
a light bulb on a stick it's very if
you're watching the podcast on YouTube
it's very elegant solution very elegant
solution so we're trying to get these
like cool spherical glass balls to set
on our desk better lamps and we got them
from Ikea and I was unpacking them and I
was carrying them back to this room and
I just casually tapped one of the bulbs
on the counter on accident like on my
edge of the counters you were walking
yeah and I think I'll just like picking
it up and it kind of like twisted a
little bit and I think that like the
thing that really surprised me is it was
just a very light tap it wasn't like a
drop it wasn't like a fumble or anything
it was just like I've tapped things that
are glass to hard surfaces many many
many times before and I just like did
not expect it to shatter and it just
shattered and a huge chunk of it fell
down and like sliced off a chunk of my
toe and I don't even know what noise I
made because I was editing and I heard
the break and I heard the aah and I was
like uh-oh
so my thought was like oh you I knew you
were putting together the lights and I
was like up broke a light and then I run
out there and I see blood on the floor
I'm like I get like every band box of
band-aids and bandages and like every
first-aid item we have glad we had
everything that we had I mean that was
really useful for like taking care of it
really quick and like making sure that
it didn't get worse than it did yeah I
just like man
toes bleed a lot always played a lot
there is a decent amount of I was like
really surprised I was kind of stood in
MERIS very analytically about it like
wow that's bleeding a lot coming out of
my toes sorry if anyone is sensitive to
talking about bleeding but yeah I was
just like really surprised because you
know we try to be safe with everything
that we do but like I just wasn't aware
of the dangers of glass I guess the
bigger glass you are talking about the
more dangerous it is it was pretty
following cameras East well it's a
pretty thick piece and this fell right
on my toe
and yeah cuz I feel like normally if we
have broken glass it's like a light bulb
or something but also it's like any time
glass breaks it's kind of like a little
bit of a lottery and like I got bad
lottery depending on like if it breaks
flat or pointy like Dicker's like you
know bigger pieces or smaller pieces so
it's just like kind of luck of the draw
whether like when you break the glass is
it gonna be really bad or not as bad
yeah anyway so that's that's my foot
story and and there's there's a little
bonus to that in the what are we digging
this week but I'll say that too later
but main channel updates recently we
revisited the very first project we ever
made further it's more of a life update
in the main channel update but it was
kind of related to the channel it was
really interesting so at the very first
video we ever made for Evan and Caitlin
was we added drawer pulls to address her
yeah to Nike address it was like an Ikea
upgrade it's so crazy to think back on
like like it that was an entire video
that was an entire video and that was so
challenging for us to do yeah and like
filming it and like figuring out how to
like do the before and after and all of
that like that was like a big
undertaking for us yep and now trying to
like think about how we would make a
video about that it seems like not silly
because you know projects like that are
very impressive and they do make a big
difference and I think that they're
great style of projects for for people
to take take on in their homes but this
is really interesting to kind of like
finger
the journey that we've been on on the
main channel from that very first video
honestly I'd like it if we could do
something like that for a video and that
was like and if the audience likes it
that means we'd be able to do more
videos than we can do now so if you
haven't seen that very first video we'll
link it down No might be interesting for
people to go back and watch our very
first watch our awkwardness it's it is
kind of interesting to kind of see how
far we've come but like we just got the
dresser because all of our clothes fit
in the two dressers we have but we just
have more additional stuff like bedding
and pillows and all sorts of other
things like hey we have room for another
dresser it'll fit in nicely there and
stuff so I kinda have a little life hack
get a dresser but don't store clothes in
it store other stuff well mainly and the
reason we want to do that is cuz right
now
extra bedding and pillows and stuff like
that was in the guest room but as you
guys know the guest room is also the
robot room meaning there's lots of 3d
printing accessories everywhere and I
was thinking it'd be really nice to put
those away in the closet so that they
don't take up so much space in the guest
room and I mean I guess we could have
got the dresser and put the 3d printer
stuff in the dresser but it makes sense
to keep it with the 3d printers and so
we're just gonna use that extra dresser
for extra storage of stuff that would
normally be in a closet yeah so I
thought that's kind of an interesting
life hack and I think that we might have
first heard that on yeah yeah another
podcast called young house love I think
they do it with like crafting supplies
but you have another dresser in their
bedroom that's not clothes yeah so young
house love is primarily a website but
they also have a podcast yeah and we've
been fans of theirs for like I've
shouted them out as my thing of the week
before yes it's good cuz well you you
started reading their blogs like 2012
years ago whatever 2010 was nine years
ago
yeah so I was exactly when I got my
first apartment I started looking at
DIYs and in gaming news it's interesting
because we just reached the threshold
for like partner status on Twitch we're
not partners yet we still need to apply
and do all the shenanigans but thanks I
think that's like it's not exciting
that's the top level you can get yeah
even though there's people who are
partners that are like obviously much
huger than we are yeah and there's
affiliates that are much cute
than we are cuz like you know it's like
there's affiliates and that's when you
can start monetizing your channel you
have to reach a very small you have to
reach the smaller threshold for
affiliates and then this larger
threshold to be a partner
so is it cuz people just didn't apply to
be partner know some people get rejected
really yeah not safe for work not safe
for work or various other reasons I'm
not really sure why people get rejected
about yeah there's well it's not that
big of a deal we can always if we can
always reapply later maybe some people
just don't like keep on reapplying we're
gonna keep on doing it cuz you just kind
of punch a few buttons but anyways I
think the reason why I wanted to talk
about it is because it's a very
interesting comparison between twitch
and YouTube and we couldn't really make
that comparison in the past for like the
main channel content like the DIY
content because it's kind of we found it
hard to continually stream that type of
content have that type of content be
live but with gaming it's perfect for
that his negatives keep on playing the
same game or different games or there's
like an unlimited amount of content that
that's pretty easy to livestream and
it's kind of like on-demand you can kind
of just like yes we're gonna stream and
that's all working and stuff but kind of
we've talked about the financial side of
YouTube for the main channel but we
haven't talked too much about the
financial side of gaming content because
we just there haven't been that many
finances the doc about yeah the gaming
channel is currently losing money losing
money but it's like paquimé it's all
part of the master plan we knew it was
it's an investment we're still investing
in it but at one thing that's that's
super interesting to me that I had no
clue about and I'm just not sure if
people didn't talk about it or maybe
they didn't have as much experience with
YouTube and twitch I concurrently but on
twitch just to give you a feeling for
our size there if you haven't been
following us there we have six thousand
six hundred followers and on average now
we're kind of like getting into about a
hundred concurrent viewers per stream
which is like pretty decent and in the
past 30 days there we've made more than
we have on YouTube we're
have twenty thousand four hundred
subscribers mm-hmm
like like 150% more or maybe two hundred
percent more on Twitch than on YouTube
which is just like really interesting to
me that like we're kind of keeping both
thing is growing at the same pace we're
putting the same amount of effort into
both kind of but at this moment twitch
is more profitable than YouTube but I
think the interesting thing is with
twitch like I can see why people like
once they get some steam on twitch it's
like well why would I do YouTube because
on twitch I don't have to edit anything
and I'm making more money yeah you know
like her per amount of time you put in
kind of yeah I think the hard thing is
if you're streaming but like if we have
YouTube and we need to take a week or
two off we would still be making money
because people watch those past videos
yeah and people can bend your content
and it has a really long life whereas
streams you you can archive them and
like people do watch our archive like
archives you get nothing for nothing
yeah you get nothing nothing from that
and you do have subs but people want to
they want to sub when you're live so if
you're not going live you're not getting
new subs and people unsub and it's just
interesting and it seems more stressful
to try it more stressful and competitive
to be like 100 percent streaming yeah as
your main source of income so I'm so
like diversifying it one one big source
of income from twitch are sub like
people subscribing so like paying a
little bit of money to like support your
channel on like a monthly basis for
example it's kind of being patrons but
it's just on Twitch yeah
exactly and for example one of the
biggest people on the site ninja he took
like a weekend off or a few days off to
go travel to a tournament where he was
playing competitively and I forgot what
like how many subscribers he lost or
something but I remember thinking like
the number he said translated to about
like a hundred or two hundred thousand
dollars worth of lost revenue from
taking like a little bit of time off
you know but there's also like the
sponsor side of things so it's like you
know and also maybe those subscribers
came back a few days later so it's like
who knows what his actual loss of
subscribers were attributing it to like
what events and what time but it just
seems like people who stream as their
main source of revenue really just like
feel like they can't take any time off
and they're just like like strapped into
this chair and they're kind of like
stuck there and everything yeah yeah
that's so interesting and I mean YouTube
has its own chair straps like and it's
it's more effort per piece of content
but there is a little bit more life to
every piece of content yeah which is why
we only have to do one video well I
guess for the gaming channel you know we
do a couple a week versus streaming if
people who are full-time streams have to
do it all off yeah but I think it's also
interesting because with YouTube you you
if you work hard enough you can get
ahead you know you can like you can
never get ahead you can like stash up a
few episodes like schedule them to go
live and go on vacation if you wanted to
or you can kind of like stretch and
compress thing that's like if you're
about to go on vacation you can start
spacing your video releases out a little
bit longer to build up a little reserve
so then you can go on vacation and still
keep on publishing content
yeah but live stream and there's no
replacement to being live because it's
because it's live yeah and I also think
that like long term I think YouTube even
though right now we're making more on
Twitch than we are on YouTube neither
number is high or impressive with those
with those sources of income but it's
just like interesting looking at the
comparison but I think that there's a
lot more potential with sponsors with
YouTube yeah because for the amount of
views were getting on YouTube already we
could ABS bunches into the mix and then
be ahead of twitch yeah if we got twitch
sponsors we could maybe pull ahead there
so I guess like it's gonna kind of be a
little bit of a continuing adventure as
we keep on growing both channels but
it's us thought it'd be interesting to
kind of touch on it briefly if anyone
was interested yeah of things changing
I don't know was that a let's let's get
into the main topic guys YouTube just
changed a lot I think and there are some
people talking about it I'm not sure of
you guys I've heard about it but just in
case you haven't heard of anything I
kind of want to go yeah give some
background so YouTube works by you know
YouTube gets money by displaying ads I
think most people know that generally
and most people also generally know that
YouTube along with every other website
and every other platform collects data
on you you know a little cookies to
track you around and and all of that
like they can personalized ads or tailor
them yeah so you know YouTube does that
everyone does that but there are certain
regulations around kids I think
specifically under 13 websites aren't
supposed to collect data on kids without
their parents permission and a lot of
companies have gotten in trouble like
tik-tok got in trouble there's been a
few companies who have gotten in trouble
for like collecting information on
people under 13 and like usually how
companies get around it like now on
tik-tok if you tribe join you have to
say I am over 13 and you can just lie I
guess but I guess they tried to put
safety procedures in place but um I know
in general YouTube strategy was to make
two different youtubes there's YouTube
kids yeah and then there's YouTube which
is like and YouTube was saying okay well
YouTube only has people over 13 and
YouTube kids have the people under 13
but obviously that's not the case
you know kids definitely watch straight
up YouTube a lot and in the past that's
been a very very like profitable place
to make content in but really in the end
what was happening as YouTube was
collecting data on kids and serving
targeted ads to them well because the
kids were using their parents accounts
hmm so that they weren't in YouTube kids
they were in normal YouTube and because
they were using the accounts of other
people like the auto YouTube algorithm
did not detect them as being
but the change that YouTube's gonna be
making now is that if an account watches
like well it's not really based on the
account but for any video that is
directed towards kids whether an account
that belongs to an actual child is
watching it or an account that belongs
to an adult is watching it there's not
going to be targeted ads on that video
because it's assumed even if it's adult
account if it's watching a abc123 video
that it's a kid watching it yeah well I
think we're kind of getting ahead of
ourselves a little bit that's kind of
the basics that's kind of the basics but
I think there's like more to it and to
got fined 170 million dollars for that
like data breached by the FCC and New
York and all of that and well that's
only 1% of their revenue it's still like
a large number and it's kind of like a
slap on the wrist to kind of steer them
in a different course and YouTube needs
to make some sort of change cuz they
can't like keep on keep things as they
are because then they're gonna keep on
getting fine and they're gonna get in
trouble so they are changing things
because like Caitlin said you know we
don't know who is watching the content
because it could be an adult's count but
it's a kid watching it
so now youtubers will have identified
the children's content they make as
children's content and basically YouTube
is putting the responsibility on
youtubers instead of on themselves and a
youtuber will have to say like this
content is for kids and if they don't do
that and it is her kids then I think the
youtuber channel might get sued yes so
they could be paying fines I think so
because like because because like if
YouTube puts the system in place for you
to flag if it's kids content or not yeah
then like it's on you not on YouTube
that's right and but at the same time if
a youtuber marks their content as
targeting kids then the youtuber gets
penalized anyways because of the things
that YouTube has to put in place so
since YouTube can't collect data on kids
it can't serve these like really
effective personalized ad
so there's still ads but their ads that
aren't gonna pay the youtuber as much
yeah and and also sometimes there aren't
enough of those ads to go around so it's
like you may watch a monetize video but
there's no ad in fact because there's no
ad to serve because YouTube like like
you know putting ads in videos it's kind
of like a marketplace YouTube has like
hundreds and thousands or millions or I
don't know how many ads but they're all
kind of queued up in certain categories
or whatever it is and when like a
YouTube video is being played the this
AI algorithm matches like someone who
wants to put an ad with your show like
in real time pretty much so it's like
pulling from a pool but if you're in
like the the bottom pool we're like you
don't get the good stuff
there might not be enough bad stuff so
it's like you may have a monetized video
and this may be nothing we'll play man
it's it's insane I mean there's a lot of
people talking about it but Hank green
has been around for a long time he's
he's been in the YouTube world for a
long time he has a lot of part of the
vlogbrothers yeah he kind of estimated
his prediction is that people who make
family content or a kid content content
targeted at kids their revenue will
probably get cut in half or more that's
crazy
which is crazy like do you know what's
interesting is like so when we look at
our back end and it tells us like the
age groups that watch our show it
doesn't show anything under 13 so if you
don't have a YouTube kids account you
may not see what portion of your
audience is under 13 yeah you know and I
don't know if it if it's like different
on the back end like if you sign up for
YouTube kids account and then you're
only on YouTube kids I don't know yeah I
don't know how you did kids works but I
think that like I mean there's it's also
such a gradient of like what is kids
content you know that's true I mean like
there's some content where you know it's
definitely not for kids and there's some
content you know this is definitely for
kids it's like counting ABC's like
nursery rhymes and stuff like that
because there's a lot of that content
millions and millions of views and
that's definitely targeted towards kids
there's some stuff like what if what if
you're one of the like DIY slime type
videos you know and
doing stuff like that that could be like
you might be a high school student doing
DIY slime videos and maybe you say like
well no my audiences other high school
students yeah that's what I am but maybe
it's actually you know eight-year-olds
or what about Minecraft Caitlyn
minecraft is technically supposedly like
kid-friendly and it's a kids game but
like kid-friendly but people who play
Minecraft are like all ages like I
absolutely love Minecraft and I am
definitely not a kid
so I mean like like is family-friendly
content kid content because it's family
yeah people gonna start like cursing in
their videos doesn't say well I cursed
so now this isn't kid content so I don't
have to check that box that's so
interesting cuz before it was like you
don't want a curse because you want to
be advertiser friendly well but it's
gonna be a fine line to walk now because
if you go too far in the extreme
direction
you're gonna get D monetized for you
know not being family friendly but if
you're too kid-friendly are you gonna be
hit by the Kid penalties now we have to
like live in this tight narrow band
[Laughter]
that's what she said joke yeah kid
that's not for kids that was but it's
just that's what she said joke every
video just like identify YouTube okay
you know right in the middle yeah yeah
but I think that there are other
features that are really gonna be very
harmful for people who are just making
kids content other things and we're
gonna link like the official YouTube
blog post about this down below but I
think that there's also a strong
possibility there will be no content
there are no comments oh yeah well I'm
not kind of something that's been in
place for some kids video yeah yeah so
that that happened a little bit ago
around like maybe like two months ago
where yeah they were disabled and
comments on like content that heavily
featured kids but now it's gonna be like
official well but that was just like any
Content that heavily had and for
just get on kids they would sometimes
disable comments Oh with like kids in
the video by now if you're watching I
don't know what kids content is out
there but if I'm just thinking of like
kids shows Blue's Clues is an adult guy
and cartoons
yes directed courts kids so like if
there was a Blue's Clues esque show yeah
it wouldn't have been flagged before for
the comment band but now it could have a
comment ban and like you know who knows
how that YouTube algorithm works in
videos where comments are disabled is
that not counted in the algorithm for or
against it so maybe is it like just a
neutral but I know that kind of
engagement of videos is used as a metric
in YouTube's algorithm and I don't know
like you know maybe if your video would
have gotten a very few comments getting
the comments disabled might actually
help you because now you're neutral now
you're neutral but if you were gonna get
a ton of comments and comments are
disabled maybe that's a negative who
knows we're just speculating here but
one thing that's definitely gonna hurt
these channels is they may not be able
to send out notifications which is huge
I mean like when we post a video the
notification goes out to like tens or
hundreds of thousands of people and they
get it on their phones and they watch
soon and that helps boost us in the
algorithm because the first like hour
the first 24 hours is really important
to show YouTube how this video is doing
like relative to the channel on all of
that stuff so if there aren't any
notifications then but I wonder why Oh
like why disable notifications what's
the logic there cuz I can see like why
you disable comments I remember like all
the scandals and stuff before that and I
you know I understand why they are
removing is because like kids don't have
like the like they don't have the best
ability to choose to watch now or later
they don't have the best ability to like
have self-control perhaps maybe I mean I
don't have much experience with young
kids any recent experience but like I
think that they kind of just like
sound kind of whatever's in front of
them to some degree you know what I mean
so if there are things being sent to
them I wonder if it's like maybe it's
something that was already like
pre-established and the YouTube kids app
like maybe there's not notification for
similar reason because like parents want
to have control over when their kids are
watching they don't want I think to pop
up and then the kids just like oh well
I'm often to the YouTube rabbit hole
yeah maybe that's it so maybe if it's
something that was already part of
YouTube kids maybe they're just like
changing these other channels that
weren't identified as YouTube kids that
are now gonna have to identify as kids
content to match the stuff that was
already any chance I don't know yeah but
also kids other things that might
potentially but they'd be disabled are
the community page and merch self which
will also hurt you know some for some
people makes that make sense yeah merch
self is like for some people it's a huge
portion of their income and but I also
understand that like when you're
marketing towards kids and you say hey
scroll down and click that link in that
little merch shelf they they may not
know what they're doing or who knows
with kids channels that do sponsorships
what are the rules there there are very
strict rules and like that seems
speaking of which the FTC who is the one
that made the rule and against Google
they're also I mean there's there's this
something that I want to tell you a
little bit later on but I'll get there
later Ryan's toy reviews it's the most
profitable channel on YouTube bigger
than PewDiePie bigger than anyone
they're making so much money the FTC is
going after Ryan story reviews there
they're suing Ryan soil reviews for not
following procedures in their videos and
stuff like that because they're saying
that like the the kids that they're
targeting don't understand the
difference between like a review that's
like a paid review and an unpaid review
and they don't because there are some
subtleties that go into some of this
stuff I mean for us whenever we're doing
a sponsored segment we separate that out
in tight this is a sponsored segment if
we're doing product placement we just
use it and kind of feature it in a way
but if you're doing like toy reviews if
you're reviewing the toy but they paid
you to review it it gets a little messy
and my Ryan toy reviews were like
wash up a little like text across the
top of the screen saying this force
portion was sponsored by Walmart or
whatever it is but kids don't understand
kids don't understand that and I can
notice they may not even notice it yeah
so I kind of understand yeah that
there's like some blurry lines there we
always try to like be very clear about
our smaller segments but also our
audiences and kids our audiences and
kids and you understand that like how
this whole thing works yeah you know and
and also I think it's different like if
we're like if your normal format is
doing toy reviews and then there's a
sponsored toy review it's a lot more
confusing you know if like the format is
the same as your normal content yeah but
I definitely like you know this is
getting a little bit farther down the
beach I kind of wanted men to touch on
this later and the future thing but like
spring up the Ryan's toy reviews and FTC
going after them I'm not sure if things
like this are gonna get less common I
think that they're just gonna get more
and more common where the FTC goes after
big youtubers or big content creators to
set examples for no no you can't do that
like this is crossing a line or whatever
they've already actually gone after
ensue game influencers and like properly
doing things in their Instagram stories
and posts the FCC has sued them and
they've had to pay like a lot of money
and what they do is they go after the
big people who have the money who like
will post about it or like you know it's
like the same way that influencers
influence people with products or
whatever if this big influencer this big
name gets sued for doing something
that's gonna cause news that's gonna get
things written about and that's going to
influence how other people influence
super-weird yeah yeah it is it is very
like Wild West though yeah you know it
just reminds me of like maybe I brought
this up before this isn't new news at
this point but it reminds me of like
there's a scandal in the beauty
community where it was like a company
would pay they got around stuff they got
around normal FTC rules by like
company a is competitors with Company B
Company a would pay a beauty vlogger to
give a bad review to Company B and so
what you paid indoors so it wasn't a
paid endorsement of their own product it
was a paid bashing dis door sment this
dorsum endorsement an endorsement of a
competitor and so they got away with it
but then it came out there's a huge
scandal yeah but like like there aren't
rules for that in place because old
media that just didn't happen but new
media it is kind of you know what I mean
it's crazy yeah I think that another
thing that's a little bit not not super
scary to me because I think that we'll
be able to you know personally get
through it all but one thing that
YouTube said is so youtubers who make
this type of content for kids have to
self-identify that hey there's content
for kids but also YouTube can't trust
people because there are people who are
try to treat the system all the time
people joining all the time trying to
cheat the system and so YouTube is gonna
have an AI algorithm scanning the
internet scan on YouTube and flagging
things it's kid content and we know how
all that works COFF COFF
robot animal fighting okay we'll do
something or whatever I mean we touch on
it a little like when one or two
podcasts ago YouTube algorithm
identified robot fighting as animal
cruelty so it's like the AI is gonna
make mistakes it's just gonna happen yes
like if you have too bright of colors
like or if you have cartoons or is it
like if you have certain tags and titles
and words in your description and stuff
like yeah our people yes I wonderful
people used to put family friendly in
there and their tags but like they're
gonna be removing that now or whatever
you could use family friendly and our
drags and it would be applicable but
that doesn't mean that we're making kids
content yeah oh it's so weird so I'm
sure the algorithm we'll look at who's
watching your videos cuz it it has that
data and if you have mostly young people
watching your videos yeah that would be
a pretty big point like if 9
percent of your audience is under 13 no
matter what's in your video your kids
Channel exactly so well it's just
interesting because like I mean there's
no clear solution in this there's no
clear bad guy there's no clear good guy
I mean it's all just like a mixed bag of
people trying to do the best they can I
guess you know cuz like crazy because
like kids channels were for a while that
was like the gold mine you know with
Ryan's choice reviews and all these all
these channels marketing to us because
certain kids just like there's just a
lot of autoplays again and again and
again speaking of which I think the
autoplay might be turned off for YouTube
kids and I wonder if autoplay will be
turned off for any YouTube video marked
as kids you know it's weird
I accidentally so I don't remember what
I was looking up I think I was like
looking up some sound effects or
anything alright which I'll look up on
YouTube sometimes cuz I was looking up
up sound effects and like I went and did
something else and I just kept auto
playing and I came back and it was on a
full length like hour and a half long
kids movie what yeah and I was like oh
god it's gonna mess up our went into the
history and I like what well that's what
they do you know that we were getting
these like little loops and stuff and
that's why kids content was so wildly
successful for a period of time yeah
going bad news I wonder what they'll do
with like some channels like like a Jake
Paul type channel for example where it's
like you know there's he was trying to
get into your kids content for a while
he brought kids on in he did
collaborations clearly stuff that is
just clearly stuff that's not
kid-friendly yeah but he is even though
like there's not non kid-friendly stuff
he's also marketing pretty heavily
towards yeah so so channels like his
channels like his are part of the
problem and part of
why the FTC needs to go after YouTube
and kind of put more clear regulations
in place how do you categorize that
because you don't you don't want that
being like YouTube sanctioned as a kid
video well restrict it as a kid video
because anything on YouTube kids is like
approved as kids content but anything on
YouTube that's marked with like this is
targeted towards kids gets like the less
good version of YouTube and none of the
benefits of YouTube kids yeah which is
interesting
how's this affecting YouTube kids like I
don't know well YouTube YouTube shows
like I like that YouTube acknowledges
that this is gonna be a hard blow to a
lot of people who make kids content
they're setting aside 100 million
dollars to help fund like additional
kid-friendly content but only a certain
number of channels are gonna benefit
from that you know there's a lot of kids
and I think that in general this is a
really bad thing for the quality and
quantity of kids content on YouTube it's
already hard to make content on YouTube
and monetize YouTube and and with this
the amount of channels who are
incentivized through monetary means to
make quality good kids content they're
gonna go down yeah I think it's gonna
hurt like people who relied on YouTube
for good kids content and I just don't
know what what the real solution is I
mean there's there's no real easy clear
solution yeah because things are wrong
before and things are still wrong now
and I think that in general yet it is
gonna be bad for the quality of kids
content going forwards yeah that's
interesting thing about cuz I was trying
to think of like other incentives they
could offer like proven quality kids
content channels and maybe that's what
part of what that like 100 million thing
is but you know depending on how much
that's spread out it's probably just
gonna be like oh here's a one-time
payment of some 100k or something yeah
whatever the amount is but that's
nowhere near what could replace
everyone's income on yes
on an ongoing basis - yeah yeah exactly
it's ongoing in
los yeah a one-time payment of some
unknown amount and also every now and
then we'll be reminded of how massively
gigantic YouTube is and how many big
channels there are it's like we're
continually like every week finding out
about some other giant channel that we
had no clue about before before that
moment yeah I'm sure it's like that with
kids content it's gotta be like a whole
nother world a whole another world yeah
I think that another interesting angle
to look at this through is through
traditional media verse new media and
traditional media I mean like TV movies
radio I guess I'm not sure and new media
it's like Instagram YouTube twitch and
stuff like that I mean with with TV
shows there's a clear very clear target
market target audience and all of that
and a rating and everything goes through
that huge review process and all of
these rules for kids content and stuff
like that were designed around TV and
they're kind of being now shifted their
focus towards new video with YouTube and
stuff like that and it's just like some
things just don't translate well between
the two yeah because I mean I've talked
to many people who are surprised at who
their audience is they think they're one
thing but they look at their metrics and
they're like well it's a whole bunch of
teenage girls you know huh well that's
why I think it's interesting that like
you may not know how much you'll be
affected by this because if you have a
normal YouTube studio back-end it
doesn't tell you analytics under 13 yeah
you know so like you might think no I'm
fine most of my audience is 13 to 17 but
that's over the 13 range but actually if
you had data for younger than that maybe
most your audience's younger than that
well another scary thing to think of is
the slippery slope argument like okay it
makes sense that they're trying to
protect young kids especially kids less
than five I mean like I was reading some
up on it and like kids 5 years and
younger they'd have a hard time
distinguishing like you know at like
not and like what all of that is and you
know beyond that they kind of start
learning but okay let's just say 13 and
under kind of need some extra protection
and everything like that but what about
teenagers you know teenagers are highly
influential or like you know able to be
influenced influenceable so it's like
what if we need to start identifying our
content as kids teen or older than teen
or whatever it is it's like like what
what if what if like we need to start
ranking more thing there's electively
and then the bots starts category
because I mean we already kind of know
that the AI algorithm bot flag is all
content for certain thing that's like
this one has violence in it this one has
this in it I mean nerd city has a really
interesting video on that that will link
below with like YouTube's hidden ranking
system and I mean I think that it might
be a somewhat theory but there are like
tags in every YouTube video with what
the bot has decided your content is
we've seen them we've seen that yeah we
have like tag zero three to seven a
whole bunch what is it I don't know I
kind of made up that number but I do
think it was something around like three
to seven or something like that I think
there's a three in the seven but yeah I
think that like well I mean I stuff you
know it's it's hard maybe people have to
self-identify for kids content because
that data isn't being collected maybe
like under 13 but for the others it's
like YouTube can see that most of our
audience is in the 18 to 24 group yeah
and then like the next highest is the 25
to 34 yes you don't really need to
self-identify too much because YouTube
already kind of knows yeah they're do
you know like who's watching it yeah and
who's actually watching it is more
important than who you think you're
making it for yeah but I guess like
because it doesn't seem to be collecting
that data or at least not showing us
that data on the normal YouTube for
users under 13 maybe that's why you have
to self-identify
I don't know it's also interesting cuz I
was like you know doing a little bit of
research before this
odd cast and I saw a lot of different
articles and I saw two different
perspectives one people upset that this
whole thing that's going on and they're
like this is too restrictive and you
know this is gonna be bad for the
ecosystem and it is gonna be bad for the
ecosystem but is it too restrictive
I don't know but on the other side of
things people were upset that YouTube
didn't get fined more that more isn't
being done to protect things that like
you know they're saying that like FTC
needs to go further and like you know
clamp down on YouTube and influencers
and influencer marketing more and that
there should be more rules in place so
like you know there's this change that's
a huge change and both sides of it are
kind of unsatisfied this is more like
everyone is upset yeah and like for us
personally it probably won't affect
anything that we do it probably won't
just cuz I mean even even like the
Minecraft on the gaming channel I can't
imagine that logically every minecraft
video would get flagged no you know but
then like if it's a kid playing
minecraft does that get flagged if it's
like a probably yeah probably any
Content made by a young kid will fall
under this category right I don't know
but what if it's like I don't know
slippery slope gray areas lots of gray
areas yeah but that FTC literally was
giving a briefing after this and they
were saying that like YouTube the
YouTube ecosystem and all the
influencers they're going after people
on YouTube is like shooting fish in a
barrel that's like literally the words I
know maybe not literally the words he
said I forgot his exact phrasing but
like he said fish in a barrel like going
after them because like there are a lot
of people who aren't doing things right
yeah and like they they could to start
soon people and finding people left and
right that's potentially
yeah yeah yeah it's just ridiculous
anyways should we move on to something a
little bit more lighthearted yes such as
a Q&A session yeah like a quick Q&A cuz
we're getting pretty far into the
podcast yeah sure we have Q&A music the
main thing oh yeah yeah okay so let's
see um this question was asked by Josh
Josh Nelson
are there any pre YouTube projects he
did together that you wish you could
have done a video for the wedding the
whole wedding wouldn't that have been
awesome like just do that as one giant
video no we should have brought but we
did a lot of projects for the wedding
that would have been really good YouTube
videos I think the paper lantern
chandelier would have been a hilarious
hilarious video cuz there isn't there
are some failure moments in that project
like when lights started falling on our
dance floor during the wedding during
the wedding or they're like okay so this
is this is my funniest moment in the
project we were so a paper lantern
chandelier is basically a chandelier
with paper lanterns hanging from it but
you need some sort of structure to hang
the lanterns from we had some leftover
PEX tubing which is just like like a
flexible tubing which is flexible tubing
and we kind of reinforced it with no I
we didn't reinforce it at all we just
like put hooks into it are you string to
like create spokes kind of yeah yeah so
we attached a whole bunch of ropes to it
and try to lift it all the same time and
I was like a like a floppy doughnut it
was like super saggy we lifted up the
first time and it was an absolute
failure well I'd seen people do it
before on Pinterest with like whoo-whee
you couldn't get a hoo-hoo big enough
for what we needed it was gonna be so
high up it would look dinky yeah yeah
another one that I would have liked to
do um was our supervisors original
litter box cabinet thank you
HAC yeah we did because I feel like that
was really good I feel like it it would
have been doable by a lot of people yeah
and it did I mean we were just blogging
at the time we weren't doing anything
serious but that one like kind of took
off on Pinterest it's probably still
like if you search you know cat box
cabinet or a cat box like you a hacker
cat litter IKEA hack you'll probably
find it that would have been a good one
I think that yeah i think that i bet we
could do it like even better this time
well we could we can like install like a
skylight for her like a like a little
like air holes ventilation make a little
brighter cozier like a little bit more
spacious and comfortable well yeah we
could definitely do a better one now
another project that I wish we were
filming was when we did the PEX piping
oh my gosh our very first home
improvement project ever that I mean our
first label main one we've done a couple
like teeny tiny things but yeah and I
know we've told the story but just
briefly we would have made a good video
video we had a leaking pipe in our attic
this big stretch of pipe and so we're
like up there in the attic and the
hospitals we just bought thinking like
we can replace this pipe ourselves and
fix the leak there's water everywhere we
couldn't get the pipe out but we had
already cut it
it's like rusty and he was looking up
online like and there was saying you
should use a blowtorch to loosen up
pipes and she's like should we use a
blowtorch in the Attic and like we
already we had cut the pipe to get it
out but then we couldn't unscrew it
because it was so arrested on even with
like multiple helper helper Bart cheater
bars and like we'd already cut it so we
couldn't turn the water back on it'll
break because we can go to your parents
and shower tonight
I think we just kept on working on it
until like 11:30 we did we went out for
some late-night burgers and those are
the best burgers my life yeah we did
finally get it but I feel like that
would have been a great a great video it
would have been kind of good in vlog for
my it would have had to be more of a
vlog yeah because this definitely wasn't
as Oriole I was like watch us fail at
releasing this fight yeah watch us fail
at being adult homeowners come watch us
panic for like five hours yeah I just
but I do think it would have been
entertaining
it would have been one of those videos
that was not fun to film but it was fun
afterwards yeah I think that was a good
question Thank You Josh right yeah it is
now time everything of the week okay so
my thing with the week relates to the
injury that I sustained earlier I have
been using a very specific type of
band-aid for awhile it's called the
banded hydrocele and it is ridiculous
very passionate about this type of
bandage it puts all other band-aids to
shame like other band-aids they pull
they like are uncomfortable they can
fold they kind of fold and and unstick
this is like putting a patch of
additional skin on top of your skin it
like just like adheres insanely well it
like forms a little protective barrier
around it you can wash your hands it
forms like a legit water seal watertight
seal around it you don't have to use
like as much like things on it there's
general you don't have to change the
bandage as much and like I think my
biggest thing though is it's just so
comfortable
yeah just insanely good gel it's not
like a paper or like a plastic you feel
it's kind of jealous yeah I think that
like blows my mind is when you go to
remove it it's like super stuck on to
your skin but over the wound it doesn't
stick to the wound so when you left the
band-aid off it just like comes right
off really nicely it's just like it's
magic it's like it's like fraud it's
like a piece of thing Tech from the
future I feel cuz like it's just insane
we're literally like we've been saying
for a while we're just gonna get rid of
all of our other band-aids and just buy
these and then after Evan cut us to
we're literally literally buying a bunch
of every different size on Amazon and
we're throwing away all of our baby
just cause like it's not the same yeah
it's like I would much rather like I'd
rather like drive to the store and get
more of this than use another that's how
you know week technology man yes that's
my thing
because it's really nice my thing is
also kind of well it is related to the
incident oh and that is my thing
the light oh yeah the light that flies
my pillow so so while Ivan broke one we
had actually ordered two because we were
ordering them for either side of our
streaming desk and so we still have one
and it's like this wanted the whole
thing is just like a glass ball with
imagine a ball but the bottom is sliced
off so it sits on a table top and it's
an or but that's maybe like 10 inches
taller so it's bigger than I thought
when I saw the pictures online and it's
cool because it's just so perfectly
round in uniform and simple and it looks
like a little moon it's really
interesting about the light is you put a
light bulb in there but you can't see
the light bulb it's so reflecting and
diffusing inside they must do some
special treatment
to the inner side of it but it's white
glass it's not clear glass yeah but it's
like like this is a hundred percent even
light throughout the whole orb so it
looks like the whole orb is glowing like
the moon and like when I saw them online
and this it's an Ikea I think it's
called fatto or fade OFA do when I saw
them online I thought they were plastic
I was like these are pretty cheap and
like they're IKEA so they're probably
plastic yeah you know and so in person
they're like way nicer and it's kind of
nice so like we didn't we decided to not
have the one we had left on the
streaming desk because we walk by this
desk a lot and we have two giant desks
in our office and we're always scooching
them back and forth in order to switch
back between our normal working
computers and our streaming / podcast we
did not want another broken glass into
there - no there so instead we put it
like on on the dresser and our better
than you at all times together and so
now it's like in our room and it's nice
because it's kind of like a little moon
it's a nice improvement it's nice as
usual we'll have links to our thing of
the weeks both related to Evans injury
yes and the next podcast we're gonna
come back with a different topic or
story not around YouTube unless they do
something else unless they do something
else crazy you'll have to stay tuned for
next week if you're watching these these
intros I just seem to like we need to
think of a standard template yes I was
how's awkwardly and then say thanks for
watching bye oh thanks for watching bye
[Music]